[Music]
the greatest saga of all time was ruined
by this film from the billion-dollar
jowls of George Lucas comes the chance
to relive the biggest letdown in movie
history in 3d all the parts you forgot
about like the bureaucratic
conversations this chair is not
recognize the senator from the Trade
Federation at this time the racism is
Shawn or Dean's or Natalie Portman's
weird robot voice more races highway and
this kind of anti-semitic thing on the
money in 3d so strap yourself in and get
ready for an hour and a half of people
standing in semi circles council
meetings different council meetings and
City just to get to five minutes of
rules done during Oscar Schindler its
Jesus fake Yoda and yousa remember himsa
miss Santa thinks this February George
Lucas defiles your childhood for a
second time in the third dimension Star
Wars Episode one The Phantom Menace 3d
cuz George Lucas hostage somewhere
[Music]
he's got big boobs like